computer science is a discipline that is
undergoing a great deal of change and
this requires that as computer science
educators that we come up with new ways
to teach the new generation of students
Alice is a system to try to get people's
first exposure to learning how to
program a computer to be a pleasant one
we have got a system where students can
make small 3d animated movies and/or 3d
video games and they do that by dragging
words in a system where they cannot make
a mistake
I came to CMU right at the point where
we were starting work on Alice - and one
of the major goals for that was sort of
the drag-and-drop interface and to kind
of get the technical hurdles that people
have with programming out of the way so
between that the fact that you can see
what's going on and you actually want to
do it in first place then we we found
that Alice was really intriguing to a
lot of people we saw that the majority
of children the majority of adults are
visual learners and Alice teaches
visually and so you get a chance to
watch what your program actually does in
a way that no other told us the work
that Alice has done in bringing these
sort of more entertainment oriented
activities into schools has been proven
through their research to be very
effective at reaching women and other
underrepresented groups showing them
that computer science isn't just people
sitting in cubicles writing code all day
but people being creative using the very
powerful capabilities of computers to
provide even more powerful and
compelling results we really believe
that Alice is one of the few silver
bullets we've seen that might be able to
turn around the massive decline in CS
majors nationwide
this is a tool that's really gonna grab
his attention and and properly used can
can really help them understand some
very key ideas in a way that is
intuitive and engaging and motivating
they are able to create things create
worlds tell their own stories on the
computer quickly and easily without
spending a lot of time mastering very
cumbersome clumsy intricate technical
software you know I enjoy the
storytelling SATA palace students learn
perseverance they get very excited about
Alice they're willing to work through it
and when they then get into job into
their mid-level classes they tend to be
willing to work harder what it builds is
tremendous problem-solving sense and it
helps tremendously with the students
programming ability what we're trying to
do with programming is allow people to
figure out how to get machines that they
have do the work that they need them to
do and allow people to do the things
that they're best at which is creatively
solving problems I've always had the
most utmost respect for trying to email
them they've always done some innovative
things over the years and I think this
is the most innovative of all we take on
the real problems here and we take great
pride in doing real things and things
that have and of course the great thing
about Carnegie Mellon is we come to work
every day and say that let's not do it
the way we've always done it let's not
do it the way everybody else always does
you